ask people for a blood donation and you
might find many volunteers tell the same
people that they'll get paid for it and
many will now decline to help
why do you think that might be
self-determination Theory argues that we
do what we do because we are motivated
by three basic needs that drive our
Behavior more than anything else
first comes autonomy we desire to have
the freedom of making our own choices
and not be forced to do something we
don't want
second is competence we want to feel
that we have the skills required to do
the work ourselves and not be confronted
with tasks that we don't understand
third is connection we want to
experience a sense of belonging of being
needed and not feel useless or like an
outsider
we can think of motivation ranging from
non-self-determined to self-determined
on the left we have a motivation in the
center extrinsic motivation and on the
right intrinsic motivation in terms of
quality they range from lower forms to
higher forms along this spectrum are
according to self-determination Theory
six distinct types represented here by
Anton Mary taichi Albany John and lalisa
who all have to study for a major exam
Anton does not understand the topic and
therefore feels disconnected to the
material his need for competence remains
unsatisfied and undermines his autonomy
leading him to lose control over the
situation
as a result he begins to think that
school is pointless he experiences a
motivation
Mary likes to learn when she knows that
if she does well she will be rewarded
but when no one is around a stimulate
her she feels disconnected Mary is not
autonomous in her studies because she
needs rewards that regulate her behavior
externally a job her mother usually does
this stage is called extrinsic
motivation externally regulated
Tai Chi strives to win or match the
performance of others when he's not
among the top his desires for competence
and autonomy are not satisfied he feels
guilty when he can't be as good as
others the root of his behavior is
therefore external this stage is known
as extrinsic motivation interjected
regulation
ebony values learning and sees herself
as a good student to her getting good
grades is important because it confirms
her self-image despite the fact that she
doesn't feel connected to the material
she does well because she regulates her
behavior by identifying with the idea of
being a good student she's motivated by
an ideal
this stage is called extrinsic
motivation regulation through
identification
[Music]
John thinks learning is important
because it makes him a better human
being to develop his intellect and
become the best version of himself he
tries to understand things even if they
are boring he feels connected and
competent but since his behavior is
regulated by the desire to live up to an
idea he is still not fully autonomous
this stage is known as extrinsic
motivation integrated regulation
lalisa learns things because she is
curious and enjoys it she can feel
completely connected to the material and
often loses track of time
studying gives her a deep sense of
satisfaction she experiences complete
autonomy and is a result of her
intrinsic interests develops the highest
forms of competence
now we speak of intrinsic motivation
regardless of where we are along the
Spectrum we all have complex human Minds
with changing interests and conflicting
desires
doing one thing we may feel fully
motivated autonomous competent and
connected but then the next day life
gets in the way and robs us of our three
basic needs we feel nothing but a
motivation
[Music]
to regain your self-determination you
might want to take a break seek a change
in environment or connect with other
people
self-determination theory was developed
by the two American psychologists
Richard Ryan and Edward DC in the 1970s
more recent research points to some
cultural differences many American
students seem to learn to out-compete
others when Chinese study hard it's
often because they feel guilty if they
do not meet expectations
[Music]
on the interplay between extrinsic and
intrinsic motivation DC said sure money
motivates but that's not the point the
point is that while money is motivating
people it is also undermining their
intrinsic motivation
so what do you think about the model do
you agree or disagree with the theory
and what do you think about extrinsic
rewards share your thoughts in the
comments below and let us know what
motivated you to do so
foreign
[Music]
this and all other Sprouts videos are
licensed under Creative Commons that
means teachers from all around the world
can use them in classrooms online
courses or to start projects and today
thousands already do to learn how it
works and download this video without
ads or background music check out our
website or read the description below
if you want to support our mission and
help change education visit our patreon
that's patreon.com sprouts